tu te jean françois forget secrétaire
général à unsa justice et surveillants
brigadier à la maison d'arrêt de
carcassonne
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord sur la
présence d'eric dupond-moretti au sein
du gouvernement votre votre point de vue
là dessus écoutez pour l'instant notre
point de vue on est dans la teinte
puisque nous rencontrons mercredi on
verra je veux dire que on a fait des
procès d'intention enfin certains ont
fait des procès d'intention à d'autres
et on n'a pas vu les résultats qu'on
pouvait imaginer
donc voilà faut lui laisser sa chance
pour autant il ira nous très franchement
ce que l'on attend de lui
ce qu'on attend du gouvernement et s'il
veut parler de de proximité si je
parlais de 2,2 de justice de proximité
si vous parlez de conditions détention
il va tomber sur sur des sur un syndicat
le mien - qui connaît son sujet qui aura
des propositions dans les faits alors
vous avez probablement très connaissance
dans cette interview dont on a parlé
donnée au jdd qu'en avez-vous pensé
j'ai pas entendu avec la connexion
excusez-moi pris connaissance de
l'interview qu'elle a donnée au jdd
journal du dimanche vous l'avez lu cette
interview peut-être qu'en avez-vous
pensé
je les lui partiellement et j'ai pas eu
tout ce qu est ce que j'en pense enfin
ça dit pas à grand chose de plus que les
annonces qui ont été les ciels les
propos qu'il a tenus depuis le début je
pense que il fait attention à peser
chaque mot il essaie de corriger déjà
les premiers égarements du premier
ministre puisque celui ci a annoncé le
retour des juges de proximité on en est
loin visiblement et heureusement
et en tout état de cause concernant les
conditions de détention puisque sur ce
sujet là et il dit qu'il veut s'attaquer
à cette difficulté la mettre en lumière
et dynamiser des projets qui sont
efficients tout à fait c'est
certainement les projets que nous avons
mis en place
l'ufap/unsa-justice ce que nous avons
proto colisée avec nicole belloubet et
pour lequel on souhaite effectivement
qu'il soit étendu sur l'ensemble des 188
établissements c'est une priorité
améliorer le
le quotidien des détenus dans les
prisons françaises ces priorités s'est
pas amélioré le cocktail le quotidien
des détenus uniquement la priorité c'est
de clairac en utile de l'incarcération
améliorer la condition carcérale c'est
améliorer les conditions de travail des
personnels et de fait les conditions de
détention de la population pénale mais
faut surtout travailler sur ce temps
utile à la castration que l' on
incarcère des individus dans nos prisons
si ça ne sert à rien si on est dans un
schéma qui propulse de la récidive en
veux tu en voilà
alors on réglera jamais le problème de
la surpopulation pénale autrement que
par ce qui s'est passé durant la crise
en vie dans nos prisons avec 14000
détenus qui ont été libérés quand même
sans aucune contrainte sans aucun moyen
suivi ça c'est pas normal
donc voilà maintenant il ya des projets
sur la table il ya des expérimentations
qui ont conduit leurs fruits
il faut tout simplement franchir un
certain cap et aux et dynamiser sa ce
que l'ensemble du territoire et a aucune
raison à ce que ça ne fonctionne pas à
l'échelle nationale mais il faut aussi
avoir à l'esprit qu'une certaine frange
de population pénale n'est pas enclin à
la réinsertion donc il faut que les
terroirs les teens nous n'avons pas des
chérubins dans nos prisons il ya une
balle et d'expérimentation de temps
utile pouvait préciser
oui écoutez nous avons signé il ya deux
ans un protocole d'accord axé sur la
sécurité parce qu'il faut absolument
mettre de la sécurité de la prison pour
engager plus concrètement l'arrestation
de la population pénale et on se prend t
rex où l'on rappelle le surveillant
acteurs nationaux à coeur c'est la
déclinaison d'un programme qui a été
engagée sur la région dijon sous le nom
du surveillant référent où on a changé
le format de prise en charge la
population pénale ou le surveillant est
au coeur même du par à coups alors on a
des petits sauts c'est pour vous
entendre j'entre a tout changé et on se
rend compte quand même que on a des
petits soucis
si pour vous entendre jean françois
forget je sais pas si vous vous nous
entendez mais en tout cas merci d'avoir
réagi en direct avec nous sur rt franc
je rappelle que vous êtes le secrétaire
général unsa justice surveillants
brigadier à la maison d'arrêt de
carcassonne